foreign
for when my daughters starts asking me
questions about my past I had a severe
drug addiction for almost 10 years the
fact that you're calling and asking this
question it's important and I'm really
proud you've been sober for how long
over four years now that's incredible
[Music]
what is going on this is John with the
Dr John deloney's show
taking your calls on mental health and
marriage and relationships and whatever
else you got going on in your world
so grateful that you have joined us if
you want to be on this show it's real
people going through real wildness in
their life and my promise is we're gonna
sit down and we're going to figure it
out together if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask that's John deloney.com
slash a s k and don't forget
kind of our gift to you if you will
Thorne t-h-o-r-n-e
the greatest supplements say the
greatest of all time I say that about
too much stuff
um they are incredible that's what me
and my wife and my kids take because
they're the best and if you go to
thorn.com you the letter deloney you get
25 off everything just it's our way of
saying thank you all right let's go to
Josue in Chicago what's up Josue
hey man are you there I'm yeah I'm here
man what are you what are you up to
dude I'm just uh Rock and rolling right
that's what we're all doing
excellent hey we all are so what's up
brother how can I help
hey man thank you for taking my call it
almost sounds unreal to be here but um I
have my stuff written out just so I can
keep my thoughts from being scattered
can I read my question then I can read
the details is that okay absolutely man
all right man so my question is how do I
get unstuck from where I've been in life
to what feels like the last decade and
I'm gonna have some stuff right here so
feel free to interrupt me whenever you
want
for the last several years I feel like
I've more and more become the kind of
person who can't follow through on his
goals and plans I'm easily distracted
and feel like I've become addicted to my
phone in media often numbing out on it
and seeking to entertain and distract
myself instead of doing the things I
should I should do I wasted so much time
this way I procrastinate my job often
because of impulsive distraction and
then I find myself stressed trying to
get the minimum accomplish but I end up
producing what I feel with mediocre work
I gained around 35 pounds since I've
been married and I failed to lose any of
the or stick to consistent exercise or
eating I don't always like what I see in
the mirror and I wish I looked different
I feel like there's very little
disciplining self-control in my life
whenever I get to a new place for a new
season I say I'm going to change and
become more responsible and focus more
productive but it's not long before I
end up doing the same thing and telling
a friend or a counselor the exact same
thing that I've been starting with for
the last few years I feel like my life
could be so much more but it's not and I
get frustrated with myself that I
haven't yet changed and I keep wasting
it away
hmm
how old are you man
I'm 30 years old 30. oh you've been
married
um
uh three and a half years about tell me
about that
my marriage yeah
um
I mean my wife is
more than I could ask for man she saw
her she's amazing she's what I call I
always joke around this issues high
functioning she she has a plan and she
executes it well
um we have a seven month old well she's
eight months today I think
um daughter first daughter and she's
beautiful too but
um since she was born life has been kind
of upside down
um just you know trying to adjust to a
newborn
um
our marriage I would say it's good I
threw it like a seven or eight out of
ten I have to rate it um we had to work
through our stuff
um how can they how
so if you are building a building and it
had four steel posts in the ground yeah
how could two of those posts be
incredible
the other two of those posts be weak and
crumbling
and unsettled in their Foundation
yet you tell me the building is seven
out of ten
eight out of ten
ah well how are you so good at being
married yet you think so little of
yourself in every other area
I was I was wondering if that's what you
were going to ask me eventually
um
I don't know man I let me ask you this
let me ask you this that's kind of an
unfair question is yeah sure what is
being unmotivated and undisciplined and
running around like your hair is on fire
all the time what does that get you
because it's getting you something
I mean so I as long as I can remember I
always play first and work hard later
and I feel like I don't get stuff done
unless there's a deadline or a fire
under my seat like unless that hammers
coming down it's like oh it's okay it'll
get done one day
and so uh letting things sit till the
last minute until I'm stressed out is
it's good external motivation because I
feel like there's not a lot of internal
motivation if that makes sense why not
I don't know because I guess it goes
back to I just I I you know why you know
why just tell me
[Applause]
because it's more fun to do what's easy
yeah I know but listen you're you're
choosing and you've probably heard me
say this uh you're choosing your heart
yeah
because like getting up and getting your
crap done and doing work with excellence
and exercising and
you know all that stuff
that's hard
yes and completely bumming out and
hating yourself who the guy you see in
the mirror is hard too so you're
choosing one heart or the other one's
not easier than the other
right why are you choosing that one
it's getting you something that's when I
get to the the core of it where does it
get you
ah what's it protecting you from pity
for mothers doing hard things I think
um
but the life you're choosing is so much
harder than mine
right yeah
um
you know John I've not
I have not asked myself that that
question that specifically I'm sorry I'm
a bit no it's all good it's okay so I
want you to keep
okay
why haven't you smashed your phone
why haven't you smashed your phone and
said enough
because I keep justifying finding some
reason why I need it no you there's
something about the situation that you
enjoy that you like that you're
benefiting from that's what I'm trying
to get to
I I like being entertained I like I like
I I grew up uh being a gamer and over
time I've let go of my games and my wife
when I married her she said I don't want
to be married to someone who doesn't
play games I was like all right cool
I'll sell all my stuff but as you know
the world has transitioned to everything
being on one's phone right and so I
might I feel like it's absolutely untrue
oh okay fair I feel like my addiction to
what was at one point games at one point
I even also wrestled at the point of
addiction I feel like that's transferred
now to Media
um I've traded out one thing for another
so anytime anytime you say the word
Addiction
I want you to think of Relationship
Challenge
okay and your body is trying to duct
tape over relationship pain somewhere
okay here's the thought that just came
to my mind
um I have noticed that it's when I have
a hard or difficult situation at home to
deal with my
typical response of dealing with hard
negative feelings to send them out
exactly and you've been doing that since
you were one kid
right and so in a memory that just came
go ahead
well no just the the memory that came to
my mind was I remember being
nine or ten and I'm being at home and I
was alone at home with my dad and I
could hear my dad in his room on the
phone talking to a woman that wasn't my
mom and I as a 9 or 10 year old
understood that that was not cool and
not okay
but I didn't know how to con I didn't
want to confirm my deck this is weird
and so I just remember saying the easy
thing to do is just to go bury my head
in my video games in my room that was my
way of numbing out the discomfort of
knowing my dad was being unfaithful to
my mom
um I have no it's just uh the same
pattern how many times have you talked
about that
uh with my friends
a few times okay several times here's
the word that comes to mind for you
powerless
when you feel powerless and your wife
comes through just like a boss dude just
crushing it
yeah
you feel powerless when your boss comes
in and says you're going to do this
you're going to show up you're going to
do this you instantly turn into a
nine-year-old kid again
and we don't have any buddies in your
life and you've outsourced all your
relationships to text messages and
emojis
your body feels completely powerless
because it cannot do anything without
close connection to other people
and so when I ask you what you're
getting from this you're getting the
avoidance of feeling reality
yes your body your body's trying to take
care of you the best it can
and it's going to do that in the short
term and kill you in the long term
yeah
yeah I feel that already
is that fair
yeah that that makes sense I I I've not
been told the word powerless before but
that makes sense I don't like feeling
like my life when reality feels like
it's spinning out I just say well this
is too hard screw this and I just go in
my mouth so I need you to to know that
when your body feels anxious when your
body feels disconnected
and you avoid it it actually gets what
it wants so what does it do it makes
that anxiety stronger
this is neurochemistry it makes it more
powerful
the longer you avoid the longer you go
the longer you just put your head down
and
um instead of snorting something you
pick up your your stupid video game
controller or your cell phone
yeah the stronger it gets
what happened that made you want to call
me did something happen
yeah I had an argument with my wife that
morning and I I reacted really strongly
um I raised my voice I've never full on
yelled at my wife but I raised my voice
or her and why and I just
ah like what happened she okay so
basically she sent me some texts the
night before and I was coming out of a
meeting at night because I was in the
meeting I I didn't text him I got home
and she was hey can you read a messages
I sent you yeah sure the next morning
she's like did you read the text I was
like look I I forgotten to do it it's no
big deal she feels that that's our way
of saying connected I feel like she's
asking me clean that's not that
important so
this irritation this rage kicked in my
heart that I feel like I've been dealing
with also the last few months and I just
said why are you I didn't say but I was
like why are you freaking out about
something so
inconsequential and then it just became
this giant argument and she walked away
upset and I was upset and so then it
just became a low day and I realized my
life is not what I wanted to be okay
because I'm not what I want to be I want
you to reframe what your wife did
and she tried to use
the streets you walk on which are
digital electronic as a way to connect
with you
So when you say it wasn't a big deal I
want you to think of her putting her
arms around you with one hand on the
back of your neck and putting her face
up against yours and just breathing for
a minute
that's what she was trying to do but
you're never there
and even when you're sitting right next
to her you're not there
when you're in your home holding your
kid you are not there
yeah and so she's trying to reach out so
to say it's inconsequential is not cool
because it was yeah
yeah so
after following this phone call I'm
gonna give you some things you are not
allowed to say anymore okay
okay you cannot say the words I can't
because that's not true
okay the words you're going to use from
this forward are I am choosing
my phone over my new baby
I am choosing my phone over my wife
I am choosing my phone over my health
okay
those are the words I'm choosing my
phone over respect and dignity
I'm choosing a video game controller
over peace
these are all choices you are making
and your body's trying to it is I mean
it's got a vested interest in this
because if not you got to deal with the
fact that you feel really powerless
that you have a wife who loves you and
wants to connect with you and you still
feel like a nine-year-old trying to hide
yeah
Fair
yeah that's fair man
so here's what we're going to start with
uh that's that's number one is you're
not gonna say the words I can't anymore
you're going to say the words I choose
the second thing is got it is I want you
to choose who you're gonna be
none of your plans or none of your
activities or none of your I I promise
none of that works if you don't have a
fundamental shift in your identity who I
am
mm-hmm
and so I'm a guy
who values people over technology
I am a guy who come hell or high water
takes care of his body I'm a good
Steward of my body so that I can be the
husband I need to be so that I can be
the dad I need to be
fair and I don't know what those are
going to be I think it would be really
wise for you to sit down with your wife
and say hey I'm working on some new
identity
you've known me for a long time you love
me we've created a human together we're
building a life together will you help
me through some of these things
the third thing is you got to develop an
identity with your wife here's Who We
Are Gonna Be here's the home we are
building
and only after you've done those three
things no more saying I can't you're
gonna say I choose you're gonna build a
personal set of identity here's Who I Am
Number Three here's who we are only then
can you get to the strategy part or the
action part
okay you know what that is
smash your phone
sell your your your video game consoles
throw your TV in the garbage can because
you're gonna lose your wife over it
yeah you're gonna grow up with a kid
wondering what was so bad about me that
I couldn't compete with a little five
inch by three inch box
yeah
now can you really smash your phone no
but I mean I could but yeah
but you can say the phone never comes
out of my car and then you know what
you're gonna be so awkward and bored and
weird for about three months because
you're gonna be sitting in your house
with no device and you're gonna be
staring at a little lump of kid that's
taking all your money and kind of ruin
your sex life and you're gonna be
looking at your wife being like uh hey
what's up and we're gonna be I don't
even know how to do this
that's the path forward
okay you're gonna take lots of walks and
you're going to with your wife and you
take lots of walks with your kids and
you can do it together and you're gonna
start cooking at home because what else
you're gonna do you might start
exercising and what you're gonna find in
three months is that every single thing
about your life has changed
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
send you four or five packs of questions
for humans and what these are they're
just tools for a guy who turns his phone
off
and then goes what do I do now and I
want you to use these with your wife I
want you to use these with yourself I
want you to use these with people you
invite over to the house
and by the way be weird man just invite
people over it might be a disaster who
cares
invite them over
and I want you to to to stop with the
beating up Josue that's not work you've
been angry and
um pissing on Josue for 20 years now
stop it's not working
when your body wants to numb out I just
want you to pause for a second and say
hey what are you trying to protect me
from
and then let's go into that storm not
away from it
and then just back up and man I got some
skills I gotta learn I've never had to
be present before because I've been
hiding since I was nine
I'm gonna start practicing being present
practice learning how to talk to my wife
and I promise she's been waiting for
this moment for a long long time
tell her everything I just told you
let her walk alongside you I'm proud of
you brother
tomorrow the light's going to be a
little bit brighter
and um
if you have some some courage man your
life's Gonna Change stay on the line and
Jenna will get you hooked up we'll be
right back
[Music]
the show is sponsored by better help
folks take a minute to think about how
much time you spend on yourself it's
easy to get caught up in what people
need from you and want from you and
never think about what you need and then
you end up too stretched out burned out
all of the madness of our current world
resting on your shoulders
look sometimes I put my head down to
work and then realize I haven't had a
meaningful conversation with my wife and
kids all day I get focused on what I'm
doing and I'm running and running and
running
and I don't know how to come back
and therapy is a great way to learn new
skills that make you the best version of
yourself they help you set boundaries
and still have energy left to help
others without leaving yourself behind
so if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
totally online to fit into your schedule
you just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so find
more balance find Wellness with better
help visit betterhelp.com deloney today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to California and
talk to Taylor Hey Taylor what's up
good morning Dr John thank you for
taking my call of course thanks for
calling what's happening
so the reason why I'm calling is because
I want to be prepared for when my
daughter starts asking me questions
about my past
and her childhood and a little bit of
how old is how old is your daughter
she's almost four
okay so so it's she's not there yet but
she I want that's why I want to be
prepared
okay I think I know where this is going
but you can surprise me so go ahead
okay so um
in my past I I had a severe drug
addiction for almost 10 years from the
age of 16 to about 25. what'd you use um
I went uh heroin and meth okay
do you have a rough childhood and I
um
yeah yeah I would say so
you started with um
it was pretty bad it was pretty bad
wasn't it
well it yes it was um it's hard for me I
don't know I don't like holding that
against my mom I just I think she did
the best she could and my dad too he was
an alcoholic and ended up dying from
that so when did when did he pass away
so before we get going this is important
the fact that you're calling and asking
this question
is
um it's important and I'm really proud
of you it's awesome you've been sober
for how long
over four years now
that's incredible especially from those
two demons because those two demons are
gnarly nothing and heroin are tough
yeah but the fact that you're asking
this question in the way you're asking
this question
suggest that you are flinching
with the conversation you need to have
with your daughter
and that Flinch comes from shame
and yes I'm sure your mom did the best
she could
but you went through hell
and you grew up in the home of someone
who deeply struggled with addiction and
then your dad died
yeah meth and heroin are often not
always but often relationship duct tape
and so I want you to drop your shoulders
and man you've got those two drugs
especially you got 10 years of
bad memories two years ten years of
things you wish you could take back that
you did right am I am I right
yeah totally and then you the light came
on
yep okay I want you to lean more into
the light than into that Darkness okay
okay your daughter's not gonna
experience what you did let me say it
that way she's got a mom who loves
every ounce of her being there
yes okay all right now continue go ahead
okay so my main concern is explaining to
so yes explaining to her my past and
also just things about her childhood too
like I was in rehab when she was born
and so there's pictures of me you know
transitioning to a a transitional
housing program for women you know she
didn't have a typical like infancy life
and so but I'm also worried that
um her dad and my sister will tell her
like really hurtful things about the
darkest secrets of my past to try to
hurt me and hurt her in a way because
we're not on good terms
um so those are the two things that I'm
really just concerned about and just
yeah explaining it this to her without
causing harm or causing her to resent me
give me an example of something that is
so dark that you're terrified your
daughter's gonna find out
um well it took me a while to get into
rehab after finding out that I was
pregnant which is horrible
um and there was some talk I I don't
I I wasn't ever serious but just talk
about alternative options as opposed to
going through with the pregnancy
so those are the two big things that um
I think that they would throw at her
maybe just in passing or just so I
missed the first the first one is you
used at the beginning of your present
pregnancy
yeah okay and does your daughter have
any cognitive delays or any
um no she does not okay physical delay
she's good to go rocking and rolling
yeah
beautiful rambunctious knucklehead of a
kid
yes yes it's awesome
okay
so just for just for the nuts and bolts
until she's 12 or 13.
any questions or conversations that come
up
you were sick and the medicine you were
using was dangerous and not good
why Mom I was really sick
and some of the sick hurt my heart and
some of the sick hurt my head and it
really clouded my decisions I made some
not good choices
that's it okay
that's it
if your sister or
the father of this child
decides to
throw a nuclear weapon into the heart of
the little girl and tell her that your
mom was considering terminating the
pregnancy they can do that
and if your daughter ever comes to you
and says Dad said this that you were
thinking about having abortion when
you're pregnant with me
you can say I was very sick I was really
scared
and then I thought of you and I thought
of this moment right here and then you
pull your kid close and you hug him for
an obnoxious amount of time 10 seconds
20 seconds 30 seconds without without
letting go
okay okay
I didn't do that I know you can
he's done way harder
the hardest thing in this Con in this
transaction is not talking to your
daughter and answering hard questions
you've been doing that for a long time
the hardest thing I'm hearing right here
is that Taylor's got to forgive Taylor
I do and you haven't yet and let me tell
you something really hard I don't want
to pile on you okay but I'm gonna tell
you the truth
if you don't forgive Taylor
in every interaction you have with your
beautiful little baby girl
is one of a flinch
is one of
a spirit of apology
that little girl will sense that and
feel that and make that interaction her
fault and she'll spend her whole life
trying to solve it
okay be fully reckless in your love for
this little girl
she won the lottery when she got you as
her mom
oh thank you do you have some stuff you
shouldn't have done yes we all do
we all do
okay
now
this is important do not use your
daughter as a way to make yourself feel
better
what I mean by that is or or to get
things off your chest
cool
yes do you mean like it's just venting
to her is that what you mean
um I mean things like
you feel like as she gets older and your
relationship gets Tighter and Tighter
that there's going to be this
set like this gap between you because
you've got secrets that she doesn't know
about
she's not your romantic partner she's
not your best friend she's not your
pastor
there's gonna be parts of your life that
she will hopefully never know about
yeah and there may be a time when she
does something dumb when she's 12 or 13
which all 12 and 13 year olds do and
she'll say something 12 and 13 year
oldish like you don't know you don't
understand and then you can be like hold
my beer like for real except you're not
drinking so hold my diet coke and I got
some stories to tell you
and my friend Rachel Cruz says Cher
don't scare right so if there's moments
that they're gonna ask uh that you can
contribute great but don't use your kid
as a as a trash can for the stuff that
you've done in an effort to try to quote
unquote make the relationship
transparent
okay keep this in your soul answer
questions that you are asked
or if you notice her pulling back or
starting to change directions or
starting to get give her opportunities
to ask questions here's the best way to
do that she's four years old now
yes what's your custody arrangement
he is I have full physical and legal
custody he uh is not willing or able to
get sober okay so so yeah
the conversation should always be Daddy
sick
he's very very sick we're not ever going
to talk bad about Dad
and I want you to create starting now a
special thing that you and this little
girl do every week
if you ever listen to the show you'll
like you'll one day I'm gonna get
sponsored by Waffle House
um kind of goes against my diet the way
I I think it's healthy to eat but
um I started taking my son to Waffle
House every Tuesday morning before
school
for great conversations for a great way
to get to know each other sometimes we
read a book together but here was the
the main goal I'm playing a 15 or 20
year game
not game I'm playing a 15 or two I'm
planting seeds for our relationship that
will that will
come above ground in 5 10 15 20 years
and that is dad loves me
and there is not a thing I can't tell
him
where his first impulse won't be to say
I love you
yeah and so if you wait until there's a
big kerfuffle or a big issue or as all
young kids ask is what happened to Dad
and there's gonna be questions she asked
what was so great about whatever dad's
using that he chose that over me that's
a common kid question and that's a fair
question and a valid question even if
it's not exactly how it plays out in
real life
those are hard moments that kids try to
solve those in all those crazy ways what
we want is three or four or five years
of relational Capital built up so that
when you look at her and say Daddy's
sick has nothing to do with you
you are loved that she'll go okay I
trust you because you've put that time
in
see what I'm saying
yes I do okay
and you don't have to hold back your
tears all the time you're worth crying
too I've heard you on this call man
you're hanging in there you're tough
stop being so tough
you've had to be tough for like 15 years
right
yes yes
you're too fun and you're too good of a
mom and you're too good of a friend to
be tough all the time being tough kind
of sucks
be tough in moments
obviously be disciplined all the time
but man
oh drop the shoulders
you've done some amazing work
[Music]
that little girl won with you
set the bricks you're caring about
Taylor down
Taylor had a hard row
[Music]
Taylor's Still Standing Tall
after all the shots were fired and all
the smoke is cleared Taylor is Still
Standing Tall when everyone around her
fail fell or bailed or passed away
Taylor's still standing strong holding a
beautiful little girl
[Music]
you're incredible proud of you
we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings in
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hallow.com deloney today to get three
months of hallow for free
hello.com deloney
Providence Rhode Island and talk to the
great Leo what's up Leah
hi how's it going
it's going okay to send out my kid has
strep so that's wonderful oh I don't get
it over the phone just kidding I'm so
sorry that's tough it's okay it's the
life of a mom right that's right is it
the last week of school or you got a
couple weeks left
all right I'm so sorry yeah well how can
I help
uh basically I've been trying to figure
out how to phrase this question but I
think this is the best way I can phrase
it just Cannonball just jump in just
jump in
actually be patient and not be selfish
tell
uh I've been with my boyfriend for six
months now I know it's not very long but
I'm like if we can get married right now
I would totally do let's do it let's
just get married right now I'm like
ready for this but
his kids are completely traumatized by
me and I can't like talk about them he
can't talk about me in front of them
like my name's like a cuss word why I
can't why why are you mean
no
no the nature of the way they found out
wasn't exactly good he didn't tell them
about me they found out about me where's
their mom
they live with their mom it's basically
the way they found out about me because
I mean my boyfriend is still technically
married they're just separated
so Leah why
[Laughter]
[Applause]
are you doing
I don't know anymore
uh I don't know isn't that why I called
James just to tell me what to do
you have your own kids
I do I have three
how old are you
31.
why are you dating a married man
I because I love him I know he sounds so
dumb but it does it does and I don't
think you do I think you love the idea I
think you love the idea of him
oh
are you the reason they broke up
no
no not divorce and separation according
to who
yeah no guy has ever in the history of
husbands said no hey we're actually
we're on the way to getting divorced so
it's okay
well yeah he told me they were gonna get
divorced in like a year yeah I believe
that kids are still in high school and
they
Leah you know
it's insane you know
come on you know that his story's not
true and you're going along with me no
no no no I I genuinely believe there is
zero percent chance none no chance at
what he's saying is true
none zero
couples who are getting divorced don't
go well you can go ahead and just hook
up with other people and we'll just ride
this out for a year or more and then
we'll go no what are you talking about
if you feel like I have to separate from
you I can't be married to you anymore
you start a process
what he has told you is absolutely
untrue and I know that you know that
right I don't I don't think it's true I
just don't understand that like why
right now since they're already
separated he can't just
go through because he hasn't told them
he hasn't told them he has he has no he
told his wife that he cheated on you on
her that's what he told her
there you go when you are the secret you
are the secret
honey you are worth so much more than
the life you're settling for
this guy sucks
he doesn't though he does and you are
falling in his heels real close
it's not cool man of course his kids
don't want to be around you his kids
have the or under the illusion that Mom
and Dad are going to get back together
they're gonna work it out
I
I even
says that are saying that they're okay
with them not being together but I've
tried to like talk to him about it to be
like I don't understand if this is what
you were gonna do anyway let me promise
you this afraid of them being hurt he
doesn't want them to be hurt he doesn't
want them to be traumatized even further
by me but he wants to sleep with you
though
he wants both
so let me be super clear this will
happen to you you're gonna be the Other
Woman at some point too
oh my God
period
how old are your kids Leah
seven six and ten months is this the
picture you're drawing up for them of
what love looks like
what romance looks like
and what honesty and
respect and dignity looks like
I'm feeling
would like to have us eventually
actually like
be together out there in front of people
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen why not why is gonna happen
because you are
Mary you're you have fallen for somebody
in the haze of baby number three
you have fallen for somebody
in the haze of the fear of being alone
you have fallen for somebody who does
not tell the truth who lies to his
children who lies to his current wife
who lies to his girlfriend
who lies to his girlfriend's kids
and is trying to keep every spinning
plate going
and it will all come down
and even if he chooses you over his wife
and his kids
what is that you want to be with that
guy
well he's no that's the other thing now
he's not choosing me over them because
anytime they need anything or want
anything he just goes and does it and do
no no I'm saying let's say he goes
through with this that he hurts his kids
even though he doesn't want to hurt him
he just wants to sleep with this other
lady but he wants everything to be fine
and good and so we're just going to keep
it secret
and maybe this divorce that him and his
wife have been working on for a long
time but they just agreed to it's cool
you can just hook up other people and
we'll just keep living together and be
married for a year or more
maybe he goes through with all that
and then he moves in with you and you'll
hold hands in public for the first time
and your three kids are trailing behind
and his two or three kids are trailing
behind your three kids and you have a
family of five or six and y'all are
sitting in a taco shop just having the
time of your life
and then some woman walks by and he
lingers a little bit too long and the
way he glances at her
and your body will remember the story
how you or her at one time
or the first time he turns his phone
over when you walk into the room
there is no way this thing plays out
Leah
and you wouldn't want to be with a guy
that walked out like that anyway
I don't know maybe you would maybe you
would
oh okay so then I don't know what to do
it like
I'm probably the wrong guy to talk to
then because I mean I I like I I
my commitment is telling the truth even
when it's hard
and
also I'm committed to not sitting down
and watching a car wreck happen
he's not gonna he's he's just not an
honest person
he's not a person of integrity
you can still want to be with them all
you want and but you're not gonna be
able to be with him and not have
relational dysfunction all over the
place
it's impossible
because he is relationship dysfunction
and you are too
what are you getting from him
what am I getting
yeah what do you what do you get from
him
well I wasn't
very abusive relationship
okay
to everything that this guy isn't he
actually takes care of me like
is that what I'm thinking how I'm
feeling he actually talks to me because
my last relationship he never spoke a
word to me he talks to you in secret and
private where no one can see or hear
and that's just until his kids are okay
but he tells me
he's just worried about his kids and
protecting them and making sure they're
not
hurt he's not he's worried about his own
but
why why
so I'm like what do I have to just be
like either gonna like do this or it's
over or like what if you were my sister
are you one of my close friends that
I would tell you that the next phone
call should be hey look I I can't be in
your life
while you're still married
I can't be in your life as a ghost
I can't be the woman on the side
if I'm going to be in relationship with
somebody I'm going to be all in
not
10 or 4 because I'm worth way more than
that and I've been abused before and
I've been treated like garbage and I've
been told repeatedly I was nothing
and I'm not doing that anymore my kids
deserve better I deserve better
and so yeah when your marriage is over
and the divorce papers are assigned
maybe I'll talk to you by then my head
might have cleared up a little bit from
the smoke of my abusive past and the
smoke of having a 10 month old and a
seven-year-old in the same house
which I've had that and it's it's
Madness it's Madness and then the only
difference between me and you is uh you
have a third one in there I didn't have
that yeah so When the Smoke Clears on
all that my guess is you're going to
want to have nothing to do with a guy
like this
but also I can't blame everything on him
no you can't
and you're a woman choosing to enter
into a family of a married man with kids
that are demonstrable how much they
think you're hurting their family
and you're like I just want to be with
him you can't do that I mean you can
but that means you lack Integrity too
man you know I have problems nope nope
nope you can't just you can't just ride
my phone I just got problems no you're
making choices
you're gonna have to heal from what
happened to you the hell you've lived
through before you just jump right into
another swimming pool
because you haven't learned how to swim
yet you've learned how to not drown
you can
it's gonna be awful it's gonna be awful
it's gonna be very hard
but over the long term you're gonna walk
six six inches taller
you're gonna have peace in your home for
the first time ever your kids are going
to know peace in their home your kids
are going to know a mother
who understands she's got strength and
she's not a person who lacks Integrity
doesn't tell the truth
and brings home guys who are just scum
of the Earth
[Music]
you're just worth so much more
and if if nobody else does your kids and
his kids do
God's sake Leah
don't I mean just be done with this
thing
best I can tell you we'll be right back
[Music]
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as you wrap up today's show I
want to thank everybody for joining us
again don't forget to go to thorn.com
you slash deloni for 25 off the best
supplements on the market song of the
day
Sugarland
it just makes me think of
that last caller's
Other Woman
song's called stay and it goes like this
I've been sitting here staring at the
clock on the wall I've been laying here
praying praying she won't call it's just
another call from home and you'll get it
and be gone and I'll be crying
and I'll be begging you begging not to
leave but I'll be left here waiting with
my heart on my sleeve for the next time
we'll be here seems like a million years
and I think I'm dying
what do I have to do to make you see she
can't love you like me why don't you
stay
but I don't think that's the truth I
don't like being used and I'm tired of
waiting it's too much pain to have the
bear to love a man you have to share
can't take it anymore
yikes
[Music]